I write most of the code I write is C++. It's highly generic. It's mostly templates. And so I'm writing a lot of function templates, and I'm writing a lot of thinking a lot about the concepts, right? The arguments have to fulfill. And so it does lead to surprising things sometimes. For example,
我写的大部分代码都是 C++。它具有高度的通用性，主要是模板。所以我写了很多函数模板，也在思考很多关于概念的问题，对吧？参数必须满足这些概念。这有时确实会导致一些令人惊讶的事情。例如，
honestly, probably one of the best days of my education from like kindergarten to grade 12 was the day I learned the quadratic. formula. Welcome to ADSP the podcast, episode 274 recorded on February 4th, 226. My name is Connor. Today with my co-host, Ben, we chat about recreational math, calculators, the quadratic formula, and more. I want to go back to something else you said, which is, so Ken Iverson used it for teaching, right? It is the case that oftentimes things are taught suboptimally, or not to a sufficient level where
老实说，从幼儿园到 12 年级，我受教育过程中最美好的一天可能就是我学会求根公式的那一天。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，第 274 期，录制于 226 年 2 月 4 日。我是 Connor。今天我和我的联合主持人 Ben 一起聊聊娱乐数学、计算器、求根公式等等。我想回到你刚才说的另一件事，Ken Iverson 用它来教学，对吧？事实是，很多时候教学方式并不理想，或者没有达到足够的深度，以至于
kids or learners understand what, you know, it's quite common that, for example, when you learn mathematics as a child, right, we start out we learn arithmetic, right? And then we learn geometry and trig and calculus. And it's not until you get to that lesson, which finally your teacher explains how trigonometry and calculus link up and maybe oil's identity is on the board and complex numbers come into the equation. And that's finally maybe the first time you realize, okay, these things that I thought were all strange, distinct techniques that I had to learn by rote.
孩子们或学习者无法理解，你知道，这很常见，例如，当你小时候学习数学时，我们从算术开始，对吧？然后我们学习几何、三角学和微积分。直到你上到那一课，老师终于解释了三角学和微积分是如何联系起来的，也许黑板上写着欧拉恒等式，复数也进入了方程。那可能才是你第一次意识到，好吧，我以为这些都是我必须死记硬背的奇怪、独特的技巧。
No, there's something underlying here. There's a language that links these things together. And at that point, it's not a point you often get to in learning something, right? So there are ways that things are taught badly, and in particular mathematics gets taught badly. One of my favorite kind of minor example of that is like when you learn binomials, polynomials, and you learn how to multiply them together, right?
不，这里面有更深层的东西。有一种语言将这些事物联系在一起。在这一点上，这并不是你在学习某样东西时经常能达到的境界，对吧？所以有些东西教得很糟糕，尤其是数学教得很糟糕。我最喜欢的一个小例子是当你学习二项式、多项式，学习如何将它们相乘时，对吧？
And invariably you learn something like foil, first, outside, inside last. Did you learn that? I actually didn't, but I think it is taught, right? So, you know, when you have like 3x plus 5 times 4x plus 7 or something, right, and you're doing just binomial multiplication. Well, that if, and for years, that kind of thing to me, I just did it. I knew how it worked.
你总是会学到像 FOIL（首项、外项、内项、末项）这样的东西。你学过吗？我其实没学过，但我认为它是这样教的，对吧？所以，当你遇到像 (3x + 5) 乘以 (4x + 7) 之类的东西时，你只是在做二项式乘法。嗯，多年来，这种事情对我来说，我只是照做了。我知道它是怎么运作的。
I wasn't actually taught foil, but I was taught the technique. But it was only years later, you know, when I was late teens, whatever, later on in my mathematical education, when I realized that that's the exact same algorithm as I had learned in grade school for multiplying like two-digit numbers together. It's just that in one case, X is 10, right? and it's hidden. But if you write out your polynomials with your, you know, units, an X's column, an X squared's column, that's exactly the same as writing a regular decimal number with units tens and hundreds.
我其实没学过 FOIL，但我学会了这种技巧。但直到多年后，我十几岁的时候，无论什么时候，在我的数学教育后期，我才意识到这和我小学学过的两位数乘法算法完全一样。只是在一种情况下，X 是 10，对吧？它被隐藏了。但如果你把多项式写出来，用单位、X 列、X 平方列，这和你写一个带有单位、十位和百位的普通十进制数字完全一样。
And then you can do the exact same, it's the exact same multiplication algorithm for polynomials as it is you learned at age six. But realizing that comes way later if that's not elucidated in your education. I was going to say if you even get that far. I don't think I've ever had that insight. Interesting. So I couldn't be upset by that because I didn't realize I'd been not taught the generic version of it. Well, you know, like Feynman said, teaching physics is the process of telling people fewer and fewer lies.
然后你可以做完全相同的操作，多项式的乘法算法和你六岁时学的一模一样。但如果你的教育中没有阐明这一点，意识到这一点要晚得多。我本来想说，如果你能学到那一步的话。我想我从来没有过那种洞察力。有趣。所以我对此并不感到沮丧，因为我没意识到我没学过它的通用版本。嗯，你知道，就像费曼说的，教物理就是告诉人们越来越少的谎言的过程。
Is that just a quote of his? I butchered the quote, but yes, that idea. It's like we start out, we learn, you know. know, Newton. And then we learned that, oh, actually, you know, Einstein modified Newton's equations. That kind of idea. Early on, massive simplification. As you progress, less and less simplification, more and more fidelity. So, yeah, I guess I'm trying to, what am I trying to do in my head? Is that, I mean, how do I feel about the fact that sometimes they're teaching you, you know, something that is omitting whatever, the full truth of what you should know.
那只是他的一句名言吗？我把那句话说得乱七八糟，但确实是那个意思。就像我们开始学习牛顿定律。然后我们了解到，哦，实际上，爱因斯坦修改了牛顿的方程。就是那种想法。早期是巨大的简化。随着你的进步，简化越来越少，保真度越来越高。所以，是的，我想，我在脑子里试图做什么？我的意思是，对于有时他们教你的东西省略了你应该知道的全部真相，我感觉如何？
I guess that's fine. I mean, I imagine that they've done some kind of study that shows that that's the best way to teach things. You can't throw everything at everyone all at once. I mean, that is the hopeful outlook that they've done studies showing that's the best way to teach things. Perhaps the more realistic outlook is that's the way it's just been taught for a while. Yeah. Yeah, I don't, I don't convention tradition. I don't know. I definitely, I haven't been moved. Your devil's advocateness has, I don't think,
我想这没关系。我的意思是，我想他们一定做过某种研究，证明这是教授知识的最佳方式。你不能一下子把所有东西都扔给每个人。我的意思是，这是一种充满希望的观点，即他们已经做了研究，证明这是教授知识的最佳方式。也许更现实的观点是，这就是长期以来的教学方式。是的。是的，我不知道，惯例，传统。我不知道。我绝对没有被说服。你的“魔鬼代言人”做法，我不认为，
like I guess I'm willing to, not concede, but I am aware, you know, I guess the strongest form of the argument is that, you know, Python has one for a reason and for people like former me that says, you know, it's just, it's not a good language for X, Y, and Z. It's like, you're missing some truth there. That being said, when it comes to like, I mean, pedmas, is the one that is topical. Like, I don't, it'd be very, I'd be curious if a listener out there has a argument that is able to convince me, but it just seems to me that that is, it's just awful. And maybe this is the whole Chesterson's fence, you know, I don't actually know.
就像我愿意，不是让步，但我意识到，你知道，我认为这个论点最强有力的形式是，Python 之所以存在是有原因的，对于像以前的我这样的人来说，会说，它对于 X、Y 和 Z 来说不是一种好的语言。这就像，你错过了一些真相。话虽如此，当谈到像 PEMDAS 这样的话题时。就像，我不知道，如果有一个听众能提出一个能说服我的论点，我会很好奇，但在我看来，这简直太糟糕了。也许这就是切斯特顿的栅栏，你知道，我其实不知道。
Why did they create this hierarchy? Is there a reason? Maybe I should go learn the reason first instead of just. I mean, I, I'm guessing, but I think, I think the reason is now in history. I think you'll find that it wasn't, it wasn't. purposefully created, it evolved from how mathematicians talked to each other hundreds of years ago, you know, and how they wrote down their equations and how they made them understood. There are some cases where we can point to this was the first usage of a particular mathematical symbol,
他们为什么要创造这种等级制度？有什么原因吗？也许我应该先去了解原因，而不是仅仅……我的意思是，我猜，但我认为，我认为原因现在已经淹没在历史中了。我想你会发现它不是被刻意创造出来的，它是从几百年前数学家们互相交流的方式，以及他们如何写下方程并让别人理解的方式演变而来的。在某些情况下，我们可以指出这是特定数学符号的首次使用，
for sure, or a particular way of writing things, you know, like, you know, Newton's, Newton's way of explaining calculus was considered inferior to Leibniz because, you know, the more symbolic ways tend to carry the terseer meanings that are more useful as you become more proficient. That's one thing we can say in general, right? You know, for most of that, particularly for PEMDAS, I think it just comes about from history, from what's been useful in history, right? It's also, it's even, it's so beautiful. It's in this conversation, I just realized, because in your acronym, and I thought it in my head, I just didn't say anything. You said, something, my dear Aunt Sally, like you said, M-D-A-S. Yeah, PM, yeah, M-N-D gets swapped around.
当然，或者是一种特定的书写方式，你知道，就像牛顿解释微积分的方式被认为不如莱布尼茨，因为更符号化的方式往往带有更简洁的含义，当你变得更精通时，这些含义更有用。这是我们可以概括的一点，对吧？你知道，对于大多数情况，特别是对于 PEMDAS，我认为它只是源于历史，源于历史上什么是有用的，对吧？它甚至，它太美了。在这个对话中，我刚刚意识到，因为在你的首字母缩略词中，我在脑子里想到了，只是没说出来。你说，什么“亲爱的萨利阿姨”，就像你说的 M-D-A-S。是的，PM，是的，M 和 D 被调换了。
Yeah, that's true. I was taught ped-mass, but you've been using an acronym that is PEMDAS. But the reality is that, you know, addition to subtraction can be either way around. multiplication and division can often be the way around. It's like reducing it to an acronym but lies the underlying ideas. The convention is more important than the acronym is what that tells me, right? Right, right. I guess that's true, yeah.
是的，那是真的。我学的是 PEDMAS，但你一直用的首字母缩略词是 PEMDAS。但现实是，加法和减法可以是任何顺序。乘法和除法通常也可以是任何顺序。这就像把它简化为一个首字母缩略词，却掩盖了潜在的思想。这告诉我，惯例比首字母缩略词更重要，对吧？对，对。我想那是真的，是的。
My critique was going to be that, like, you know, you can just have different acrony. It's a flaw of the hierarchy of operations that we apply. But I guess that's not actually the concrete algorithm is there's a set of operations you do, then another set, then another set. The order within that set doesn't matter. And all these, you know, a lot of times you see. see these, I hesitate to call them memes, but they go around the internet saying, you know, what's the answer to this? And it relies on applying some version of that. But oftentimes,
我的批评是，就像，你知道，你可以有不同的首字母缩略词。这是我们应用的运算等级制度的一个缺陷。但我猜那不是实际的算法，有一组运算要做，然后是另一组，再另一组。该集合内的顺序并不重要。所有这些，你知道，很多时候你看到……看到这些模因，我不想称它们为模因，但它们在互联网上传播，说，这个问题的答案是什么？它依赖于应用该版本的某种形式。但很多时候，
whenever one of those comes across my feet, I look at it and I think, well, that, you know, the question on its face is ridiculous because nobody who wanted, no mathematician, nobody who wanted to be clear about conveying the intent of their equation would write that in the first place, right? Nobody would write that. So, The fact that it's some kind of puzzle that's supposed to be you're good at mathematics if you get this, no, that's ridiculous. See, it's so funny that, like, because in my head, there's a little voice screaming right now that's going, like, isn't it a clear flaw of the articulation of that math equation
每当其中一个出现在我面前时，我看着它，我想，嗯，那个问题表面上是荒谬的，因为任何想要清楚地传达其方程意图的人，任何数学家，都不会首先那样写，对吧？没有人会那样写。所以，它是一种谜题，如果你答对了就说明你擅长数学，不，这太荒谬了。看，这太搞笑了，因为在我的脑海里，现在有一个小声音在尖叫，说，难道那不是那个数学方程表达的一个明显缺陷吗？
that no one would write it that way? It's like, that's because pedmas is terrible. Like, you would communicate it with brackets or parentheses to, like, make your intent clear. And it's like, you don't need any of that for APL. You know, it's like, and this is an argument for APL. This is an argument against the order of evaluation that is necessitated by pedmas and bodmas or whatever. Well, there's particularly, the particular sort of poor candidate here is division, right? Because invariably, whenever you see this online, it's like the divide symbol, you know, the hyphen with two dots on either side.
没有人会那样写？这就像，那是因为 PEMDAS 太糟糕了。就像，你会用括号或圆括号来交流，以使你的意图清晰。这就像，对于 APL，你根本不需要这些。你知道，这就像，这是支持 APL 的一个论点。这是反对 PEMDAS 或 BODMAS 等所必需的求值顺序的论点。嗯，这里特别糟糕的候选者是除法，对吧？因为总是，每当你在网上看到这个时，它就像除号，你知道，两边有两个点的连字符。
And I don't know. Maybe it's just me, but I don't know. anyone who's used that symbol since grade school. Like, anyone who actually manipulates numbers like that and equations, they just write a fraction. You know, they'll use the other dimension. You know, computers, in some sense, for a while at least reduce this to kind of one-dimensional equations, and that was also a problem.
我不知道。也许只是我，但我不知道有谁从小学起就用过那个符号。就像，任何真正那样操作数字和方程的人，他们只会写一个分数。你知道，他们会使用另一个维度。你知道，计算机在某种意义上，至少有一段时间把这些简化为一维方程，那也是一个问题。
Yeah, it's true. You've just got the line. But in reality, nobody does that when they actually write things on paper or when they want to even, you know, type set a paper for me. mathematics, of course. Yeah, yeah. I mean, that's true. I mean, on my favorite calculator of all time, the, I believe, it's been years since I've
是的，那是真的。你只有那一行。但实际上，当人们真正把东西写在纸上，或者当他们甚至想为我排版一篇论文时，没有人会那样做。当然是数学。是的，是的。我的意思是，那是真的。我的意思是，在我有史以来最喜欢的计算器上，我相信，我已经好几年没用过这些计算器了，
had one of these calculators, a Ti-30XS multi-view. I believe it has the ability to... Okay, you're wrong? You're wrong? This is the best calculator of all time. Ben was reaching for something. I was like, is he about to pull out the Ti-30XS multi-view? But no, it's a Casio.
Ti-30XS MultiView。我相信它有能力……好吧，你错了吗？你错了吗？这是有史以来最好的计算器。Ben 伸手去拿什么东西。我在想，他是不是要拿出 Ti-30XS MultiView？但不是，它是卡西欧。
This is the Cassio FX-150D. It's how, okay. hour, this episode started in like Toronto, Canada and ended up in like Tanzania. Why is this the best calculator? Well, it's, it is sort of peak non-graphical calculator, in my opinion. So I've had this calculator for 35 years. It's still working. It's solar powered.
这是卡西欧 FX-150D。它是怎么……好吧。这一集开始于加拿大多伦多，最后到了坦桑尼亚。为什么这是最好的计算器？嗯，在我看来，它是非图形计算器的巅峰之作。所以我用这个计算器 35 年了。它还在工作。它是太阳能供电的。
It still works fine. What makes it very good in particular, the thing that I use it for, and sometimes still use it for, less so these days, but it has sort of one touch binary decimal hex conversion. That is really good. I don't think the 30XS multi-view has that. In fact, I'm sure if your calculator is pre-grafing calculator, it's got an order of magnitude more functionality. I'm just looking at the key set.
它仍然工作得很好。是什么让它特别好，我用它做的事情，有时仍然用它，虽然现在少了，但它有一种一键式二进制、十进制、十六进制转换。这真的很好。我不认为 30XS MultiView 有这个功能。事实上，我敢肯定，如果你的计算器是预图形计算器，它的功能要多一个数量级。我只是在看按键。
The main thing that was nice about the 30XS was for at least the actual. exams because it was an actuarially an S-O-A-approved calculator. It had the, you know, it would show you a square root or like a fraction. And a lot of times there are multiple choice questions actually have them in the pure form or whatever, not the rational floating point form. And you could also, and you could store stuff in variables as well, which I imagine yours, if yours is pre-grafing calculator, I'm sure they have that functionality. So that's another thing of like progress in mathematical education, right?
30XS 的主要优点是至少对于实际考试来说，因为它是一个精算师协会（SOA）批准的计算器。它有，你知道，它会向你显示平方根或分数。很多时候，多项选择题实际上有纯形式或什么的，而不是有理浮点形式。而且你还可以将东西存储在变量中，我想你的，如果你的计算器是预图形计算器，我相信它们有这个功能。所以这是数学教育进步的另一件事，对吧？
sometime when you're around, oh, I don't know when it might be 11, 12, there's a point where you need to learn when you're solving an equation, you know, if the answer is, let's say, root 3, just write root 3. Do not write the decimal. Oh, yeah. Right? The answer is root 3, that's fine. Yeah. Yeah, that's very true. I don't know at what point I went. And that also just made me think that the lies that we were told in our education, you know, I don't know why I did this, but every summer we would drive either north or south. I lived in the middle of nowhere in British Columbia, a city called Prince George. And so we'd always drive to visit my grandparents. One was in Terrace and one was in Vancouver. And each one is eight hours and one's ten hours. And sometimes I would just take math. I'd take a sheet of like loose leaf and like write some random math equation with X's and things.
有时当你大约，哦，我不知道什么时候，可能是 11、12 岁，有一个点你需要学习，当你解方程时，你知道，如果答案是，比如说根号 3，就写根号 3。不要写小数。哦，是的。对吧？答案是根号 3，那很好。是的。是的，那非常正确。我不知道我什么时候学会的。这也让我想到了我们在教育中被告知的谎言，你知道，我不知道为什么我这样做，但每年夏天我们都会开车向北或向南。我住在不列颠哥伦比亚省一个叫乔治王子城的地方，那里荒无人烟。所以我们总是开车去探望我的祖父母。一个在特勒斯，一个在温哥华。每个都要八小时，一个是十小时。有时我只是拿数学题。我会拿一张活页纸，写一些带有 X 和其他东西的随机数学方程。
And then I would just solve it. This is just something that passed the time. And every once in a while you end up with X squared. I'm like, you're like, oh, I put a bad combination. an incorrect combination at the top because it was before like grade eight when they taught you the quadratic formula and then I'm sitting in class one day and then teach you the quadratic formula and I was like, you're telling me this whole time there was a formula for solving this and I thought I was doing something wrong. What the hell? And I guess that's just an example
然后我就解出来。这只是打发时间的事情。偶尔你会得到 X 平方。我心想，你就像，哦，我在顶部放了一个糟糕的组合，一个不正确的组合，因为那是在八年级教你求根公式之前，然后有一天我坐在教室里，老师教你求根公式，我就想，你是在告诉我，一直以来都有一个解这个的公式，而我以为我做错了什么？搞什么鬼？我想这只是一个例子
of not having gotten to that point yet. Yeah, the quadratic formula to me always feels like cheating. I don't know if it feels like it, but like because it feels like it feels impure. If I have to break out the quadratic formula to solve an equation, it means, usually it means that I'm looking for some real answer. Like, I'm looking for a decimal, you know, a real number. Like, that to begin with is somehow impure, maybe. But it feels like, you know, I don't know, breaking out the quadratic equation, it's fine, but it feels like, you know, it feels like taking sugar in your tea. Really? So you're not a big fan of the quad. Honestly, probably one of the best days of my education from like kindergarten to grade 12 was the day I learned the quadratic formula. I would much rather, I mean, it's expedient and it's fine and it's good, but aesthetically, I would much rather solve a quadratic equation by inspection or by completing the square or some other method rather than breaking out just having to full, it feels like a fullback.
还没到那个阶段。是的，求根公式对我来说总是感觉像作弊。我不知道它是否感觉像，但就像因为它感觉不纯粹。如果我必须拿出求根公式来解方程，这意味着，通常意味着我在寻找某个实数答案。就像，我在寻找一个小数，你知道，一个实数。就像，这本身在某种程度上是不纯粹的，也许。但它感觉就像，我不知道，拿出求根方程，这很好，但它感觉就像，你知道，它感觉就像在你的茶里加糖。真的吗？所以你不是求根公式的忠实粉丝？老实说，从幼儿园到 12 年级，我受教育过程中最美好的一天可能就是我学会求根公式的那一天。我宁愿，我的意思是，它很方便，很好，也很有用，但从美学上讲，我宁愿通过观察或配方法或其他方法来解二次方程，而不是拿出……它感觉就像一个后备方案。
It feels like I couldn't solve this by any other method, so I had to use the quadratic equation. I don't know. Maybe it's just me. Yeah, interesting. I've never, I've never, I mean, I guess it was my path to the quadratic formula. I had run into all these equations that I had mangled together myself and then this was the, and I guess I didn't have graph paper. I wasn't drawing these curves and then, you know, circling points and estimating. When I was in grade school, what age was I? Let's say 13, 12, 13, so second year of secondary school, I think it was.
它感觉就像我不能用任何其他方法解这个，所以我不得不使用求根方程。我不知道。也许只是我。是的，有趣。我从来没有，我从来没有，我的意思是，我想这是我通往求根公式的道路。我遇到了所有这些我自己胡乱拼凑的方程，然后这是，我想我当时没有坐标纸。我没有画这些曲线，然后，你知道，圈出点并进行估算。我在小学时，我多大？比如说 13、12、13 岁，所以我想是中学二年级。
I was lucky enough to have a recreational mathematics class on the syllabus. Once a week, one period, recreational mathematics. David Beckwith was the teacher. If you're out there, thank you very much. But it was a great class. And what made it great was just that it was, it was a class where the students, Firstly, we got to collaborate on problems, right, which is great, which normally you don't get to do because, you know, the structure of education means you have to be tested and you have to make sure that individually you know it. No, in the recreational mathematics class, the teacher would throw out a problem and solicit ideas from the class, right? And then over the course of two weeks, three weeks, the class would get towards a solution to the problem. and solve sub-problems long the way, maybe split into groups.
我很幸运在教学大纲里有一门娱乐数学课。每周一次，一节课，娱乐数学。David Beckwith 是老师。如果你在听，非常感谢你。但这门课很棒。让它变得伟大的是，它是一门学生们可以合作解决问题的课，对吧，这很棒，通常你做不到，因为，你知道，教育结构意味着你必须接受测试，你必须确保你个人知道它。不，在娱乐数学课上，老师会抛出一个问题并征求班级的想法，对吧？然后在两周、三周的时间里，班级会朝着问题的解决方案前进，并在此过程中解决子问题，也许分成小组。
It was that kind of a class. Really, really good. I remember it to this day. That sounds very. I would have died for a class like that. Well, not die. I guess that's a bit, I would have. Well, I was about to say killed, but I also wouldn't have killed.
就是那种课。真的，真的很好。我至今记忆犹新。听起来很棒。我会为了那样的课而死。嗯，不是死。我想那有点，我会。嗯，我本来想说杀了，但我也不会杀。
All these bad figure of speeches. An example problem would be he'd come into class and he'd say, you know, how many squares are there on a chessboard? And someone would put the hand up and say, of course, they're 64. And he'd say, okay, so you're counting the one. one by one squares. At that point, everyone's mind expands a little bit,
所有这些糟糕的比喻。一个例子问题是他会走进教室说，你知道，棋盘上有多少个正方形？有人会举手说，当然，有 64 个。他说，好吧，所以你在数 1x1 的正方形。在那一刻，每个人的思维都扩展了一点，
and they're like, oh my gosh. And so then we go away, we work on that problem, we come back with the answer. And then he says, well, what if the chess board had a side length of,
他们就像，哦，天哪。所以我们就离开，去研究那个问题，我们带着答案回来。然后他说，好吧，如果棋盘的边长是，
side length of N? Can you figure that out? We go away, we do that. And he's like, okay, what about now if it's rectangular? How many rectangles are there?
边长为 N 呢？你能算出来吗？我们离开，我们做了。他说，好吧，如果是矩形呢？有多少个矩形？
Not just squares. So that was the kind of way that the class proceeded, right? It was that kind of open-ended problem where you just keep adding generalizations or maybe you keep adding constraints and over time you know everyone's mind gets broadened what grade was this second year of secondary school so i'm going to find it hard to
不仅仅是正方形。所以这就是课程进行的方式，对吧？就是那种开放式的问题，你只是不断添加概括，或者也许你不断添加约束，随着时间的推移，你知道每个人的思维都得到了拓宽。这是几年级？中学二年级，所以我很难
answer your question because i don't know how grade numbers go and the school i went to did not use conventional grade numbers but it would be when i was 12 turning 13 okay so it's for i mean at least for canada i don't even know i assume america and other parts but we call that either junior high school, but it's like you've got three or four years left in your... Yeah, yeah, it's pre-high school, pre-U.S. High School, for sure. Pre-GCSE in the UK. Recreational math. I mean, recreational... We've talked about so many things now, you know, my complaints about a lot of stuff.
回答你的问题，因为我不知道年级数字是怎么排的，我上的学校不使用传统的年级数字，但那应该是我 12 岁快 13 岁的时候。好的，所以对于，我的意思是至少对于加拿大，我甚至不知道，我假设美国和其他地方，我们称之为初中，但就像你还有三四年时间……是的，是的，这是高中前，美国高中前，肯定的。英国的 GCSE 前。娱乐数学。我的意思是，娱乐……我们现在聊了这么多东西，你知道，我对很多事情的抱怨。
I mean, what is the... I mean, the... What did I write? What was my exact thing that I wrote in the email? It was algorithmic... Algorithmic truth we've mentioned, full-up on inverse plus scan, array box.dev which you pulled up. So yeah and then finally recreational math. The other thing about recreational math is
我的意思是，什么是……我的意思是……我写了什么？我在电子邮件里写的确切内容是什么？是算法……我们提到的算法真理，关于逆加扫描的后续，你调出的 arraybox.dev。所以是的，最后是娱乐数学。关于娱乐数学的另一件事是
I grew up geeking out reading those kind of books which is like you know, amuse your friends and confound your enemies kind of things. You know and it's when you have kids it's great because you can you know blow their mind in all sorts of different ways with these silly little number
我从小就喜欢读那些书，就像，你知道，娱乐你的朋友，困惑你的敌人之类的东西。你知道，当你有了孩子，这很棒，因为你可以，你知道，用这些愚蠢的小数字问题以各种不同的方式让他们大吃一惊，
problems, you know. It's like the thing about you know take any three digit number reverse it, take it away from itself, or do the subtraction, then reverse and do the subtraction again. And you always, I think that's the algorithm. And you always get 1,089. Like it's just, it's a way.
你知道。就像关于你知道取任何三位数，反转它，从它本身减去，或者做减法，然后反转并再次做减法。你总是，我想那是算法。你总是得到 1089。就像它只是一种方式。
And on the face of it, it looks amazing. It's like, you always get, you guessed my number? How did you do that? Well, you always get that. And the reason why you always get that is a structural property of the base 10 and the place value system, right? It's just the way it works out. Things like that. It's things like knowing, you know, knowing the decimal expansion of one seventh and that kind of cyclic. Cycical fraction. Right. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So, like, I went out to karaoke and there were seven of us,
表面上看，它看起来很神奇。就像，你总是得到，你猜到了我的数字？你是怎么做到的？嗯，你总是得到那个。你总是得到那个的原因是十进制和位值系统的结构属性，对吧？它就是这样运作的。像那样的事情。就像知道，你知道，知道七分之一的十进制展开和那种循环。循环分数。对。是的，是的，是的。所以，就像，我出去唱卡拉 OK，我们有七个人，
and the bill at the end of the evening was $200. And someone says, how much is that per person? I say, well, it's 2857. And the hostess is reaching for a calculation. She's like, how do you know that so fast? Like, there's two seventh. 200 divided by 7 Yeah, it's funny because I always memorized the like to four digits one seventh and then for like years didn't I think I tweeted it out the day that I realized it
晚上结束时的账单是 200 美元。有人说，每人多少钱？我说，嗯，是 28.57。女主人正在拿计算器。她就像，你怎么知道得这么快？就像，那是七分之二。200 除以 7。是的，很有趣，因为我总是记住了七分之一的四位数字，然后好几年没想过，我那天发推特说我意识到了
I was like just realized today because I was messing around an APL with like formatting I don't know seventh fractions that they all had the same character set and I was like who knew? And I thought I was like discovering something cool and then everyone on Twitter was like yeah here's the Wikipedia paid on cyclic fractions
我就像今天刚刚意识到，因为我在 APL 里摆弄格式，我不知道七分之一的分数，它们都有相同的字符集，我就想，谁知道呢？我以为我发现了什么很酷的东西，然后推特上的每个人都说，是的，这是关于循环分数的维基百科页面
and I was just like oh there's other like you know, obviously you know about 1 9th and 1 3rd and all those ones and 111 sure, sure. But 1 7th is to, what is it, six digits, 1, 1429, something, something. 1428-7. Yeah.
我当时就想，哦，还有其他像，你知道，显然你知道九分之一和三分之一以及所有那些，还有 111，当然，当然。但七分之一是到，是多少，六位数字，142857。142857。是的。
So that one's a lot harder to just like observe, right? And it's cyclic. And of course, if you multiply by 7, you get 9-999-999. Because the, you know, because it's repeating, the extra 1-7th of that part is cut off effectively. So yeah, it makes you look amazing to your friends
所以那个很难仅仅通过观察得到，对吧？而且它是循环的。当然，如果你乘以 7，你会得到 9999999。因为，你知道，因为它是重复的，那部分多出的七分之一实际上被切掉了。所以是的，这让你在朋友面前看起来很棒
when you just have, you know, when numbers are, when you, who was it who said like, maybe it was fine, and maybe it was someone else, but it's like, or it was said of Romanovian that every, every, every number was his friend. Right. Right. So, you know, when you, when you, when you, when you think of numbers, not just as just the number that you've learned by road, but with, with, with all of it's a web of, of interactions with other numbers, like, those kind of things. Then that, that, that, that, that, that kind of thing is what recreational mathematics opens your mind to, I think. Yes. Yeah. What is it? What's the name of that movie that has... The Man New Infinity? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, with Def Patel playing Ramonajon. Yeah, there's a scene in that movie. I thought for sure I had included that clip
当你只是有，你知道，当数字是，当你，是谁说像，也许是费曼，也许是别人，但就像，或者有人说拉马努金，每个数字都是他的朋友。对吧。对吧。所以，你知道，当你，当你，当你，当你想到数字时，不仅仅是你死记硬背学到的数字，而是带着，带着，带着它与其它数字的所有互动网络，就像，那些事情。那么那，那，那，那，那，那，那种事情就是娱乐数学为你打开的思维，我想。是的。是的。那是什么？那部电影的名字是什么，有……《知无涯者》？是的，是的，是的，是的，戴夫·帕特尔饰演拉马努金。是的，那部电影里有一个场景。我以为我肯定把那个片段放进去了
in my sick P-CP con talk from like years ago where he gets out of the taxi and says, oh, what an unremarkable number. What are you talking about? Sorry, I'm late. Doughty cab driver got lost. Should have known for his number. And what was that? More a dull one. 1729. No, Hardy. It is a very interesting number.
在我几年前的 CppCon 演讲中，他从出租车里出来说，哦，多么平庸的数字。你在说什么？抱歉，我迟到了。笨拙的出租车司机迷路了。应该知道他的数字。那是什么？更无聊的一个。1729。不，哈代。这是一个非常有趣的数字。
It is the smallest number expressible as a sum of two cubes in two different ways. Oh, that, yes. Taxi cap numbers. The taxi cab numbers. 1729, which is like a nice little Easter egg because there's tons of folks. I think you, STL, Stefan Lowaway, he sneaks those in. Yeah, stuff like that. I don't remember.
它是最小的能以两种不同方式表示为两个立方数之和的数字。哦，那个，是的。出租车数。出租车数。1729，这就像一个不错的小彩蛋，因为有很多粉丝。我想你，STL，Stefan Lowaway，他把这些塞进去了。是的，类似的东西。我不记得了。
I feel like maybe when I was super young, I used to have the birthday tricks where it's like take your birthday and do something to it, and then I can reverse engineer your birthday with some simple trick. But I don't fully remember if I actually, like, had any of those. I spend too much time in combinatorial logic land. And that is, that's a reason why I love, you know, because, I mean, one of the, I don't know if it is a through line through this conversation, because we've been, we've been.
我觉得也许当我非常年轻的时候，我曾经玩过生日把戏，就像取你的生日并对它做些什么，然后我可以用一些简单的技巧逆向工程出你的生日。但我不太记得我是否真的，就像，有任何那些。我花太多时间在组合逻辑领域了。这就是为什么我喜欢，你知道，因为，我的意思是，我不知道这是否是贯穿这次对话的一条主线，因为我们已经。
All over the show. Yeah. Was it Papuskin dolls, the Russian dolls or whatever? Matrashka dolls? Matrashka dolls. You know, we're so many tangents deep on some of these that we might have lost sight of the algorithmic truth and the recreational algorithms and math is that that is why I love combinator logic so much is because, you know, on my quest for algorithmic truth in, you know,
到处都是。是的。是俄罗斯套娃吗？套娃？套娃。你知道，我们在其中一些问题上跑题太深，以至于我们可能忽略了算法真理和娱乐算法，数学就是我如此热爱组合逻辑的原因，因为，你知道，在我追求算法真理的过程中，你知道，
criticizing adjacent difference and discovering unplus scan and all this stuff, you know, sometimes it feels like you have really found like the underlying generic. And that is, you know, the kind of the pursuit of generic programming as well is what is the most generic form of this algorithm, you know, there's a connection between generic programming and algorithms and whatnot. And combinator logic, it's like the purest form of anything that I've come across because it's just like composition patterns, you know, like it's so obvious when you're applying in some pattern, you know, a unary operation and a binary operation, it's like, well, clearly,
批评相邻差分并发现扫描加法和所有这些东西，你知道，有时感觉你真的找到了像潜在的通用形式。而且，你知道，这也是通用编程的追求，什么是这个算法的最通用形式，你知道，通用编程和算法之间有联系。而组合逻辑，它就像我遇到的任何东西中最纯粹的形式，因为它就像组合模式，你知道，就像当你应用某种模式时，你知道，一元运算和二元运算，这就像，嗯，显然，
this is, there's no debating that this is the insert, you know, B1 combinator or I combinator or whatever. They've got fancy names, which is a whole other thing. It's like, well, that's the convention. Well, it's a terrible convention. And I think most people would agree it's a terrible convention because it doesn't mean anything. And it's like, whereas at least everybody knows pedmas. Anyways, there's something here, but it's just like it's the, it's the pursuit of this stuff that's like undeniably beautiful and there's like nothing below it. And to bring it back to APIs, you know, to bring back to an application here rather than pure mathematics. It's the same
这是，毫无疑问，这是插入，你知道，B1 组合子或 I 组合子之类的。它们有花哨的名字，这是另一回事。这就像，嗯，那是惯例。嗯，这是一个糟糕的惯例。而且我认为大多数人会同意这是一个糟糕的惯例，因为它没有任何意义。这就像，而至少每个人都知道 PEMDAS。无论如何，这里面有些东西，但这就像它是对这些东西的追求，就像不可否认的美丽，下面什么都没有。为了把它带回 API，你知道，为了带回一个应用，而不是纯数学。这是同样
kind of feeling, right? When you write a really nice piece of code, when you get an API correct, most of the code I write is C++. It's highly generic. It's mostly templates. And so I'm writing
的感觉，对吧？当你写一段非常好的代码，当你把 API 做正确时，我写的大部分代码都是 C++。它具有高度的通用性，主要是模板。所以我写
a lot of function templates, and I'm writing a lot of thinking a lot about the concepts, right? The arguments have to fulfill. And so it does lead to surprising things, times. For example, I have an API where it does an I.O. And there's a read function and a right function. Okay. Now, now, the surprising thing is that, so, okay, so what does the right
了很多函数模板，也在思考很多关于概念的问题，对吧？参数必须满足这些概念。所以它确实会导致令人惊讶的事情，有时。例如，我有一个 API，它做 I/O。有一个读函数和一个写函数。好的。现在，令人惊讶的是，所以，好的，那么写
function take? Well, being very generic, it takes a right specification, right? It takes, it takes, and the specification is data plus where to write it. Okay. Just staying very high level here. What does the read function take? Well, again, it takes a read specification, which is where to read from, right? Because it's going to produce the data. So what does the read function return? Well, you want to be able to write what you've just read. So the read function actually returns a right specification.
函数接受什么？嗯，非常通用，它接受一个写规范，对吧？它接受，它接受，而规范是数据加上写在哪里。好的。在这里保持非常高的水平。读函数接受什么？嗯，同样，它接受一个读规范，也就是从哪里读，对吧？因为它会产生数据。那么读函数返回什么？嗯，你想要能够写下你刚刚读到的东西。所以读函数实际上返回一个写规范。
It takes in a read spec, which is locations from where to read, and it produces those locations tied together with the data that it read. And that is a right spec. So what this means is that if you include the read header, because it returns the right specification, it needs the definition of it, right? So somewhat surprisingly, the right specification definition is entailed by the reading, right? And not actually by the writing, because what the right function takes is not a concrete right specification, but something that fulfills a concept. It doesn't actually need the definition of a concrete thing, right? Because when you get to that level of generosity,
它接收一个读规范，也就是从中读取的位置，并产生这些位置，并与它读取的数据绑定在一起。这就是一个写规范。所以这意味着如果你包含读头文件，因为它返回写规范，它需要它的定义，对吧？所以有点令人惊讶的是，写规范定义是由读取所蕴含的，对吧？而不是由写入所蕴含的，因为写函数接受的不是一个具体的写规范，而是满足某个概念的东西。它实际上不需要具体事物的定义，对吧？因为当你达到那种通用性水平时，
these are the kind of surprising effects you discover. There's asymmetry there. Yeah. Like, you would think that, you would think that, you know, right specification goes along with the right function. But that's not actually true. It goes along with the read function because that's what's returned, and therefore you need to know a concrete thing to return.
这些就是你发现的令人惊讶的效果。那里有不对称性。是的。就像，你会认为，你会认为，你知道，写规范与写函数一起。但那实际上不是真的。它与读函数一起，因为那是返回的内容，因此你需要知道一个具体的东西来返回。
Just a small observation I had lately. Yeah, yeah. I mean, those are the things you end up thinking about when you're going for a walk or, or I don't know if it's the stuff that you're thinking about when you're going for a walk. But I spend an inordinate amount of time. Sometimes I'll be listening to a podcast and then even if it's, it is an interesting podcast. If there's something interesting that I was thinking about or designing, I have to turn the podcast off and just like, clearly my brain wants to think about whatever, that problem is there a better way to. Yeah, when your mind is quiet, I have a talk about that. I'm not sure it's very well grounded in fact, but it is an experiential talk I gave at our local meetup a while back, about this idea of bringing both sides of your mind to work on a problem. The talk was called the Blacksmith and the Gardner. Oh, yes.
只是我最近的一个小观察。是的，是的。我的意思是，这些就是当你去散步时最终会思考的事情，或者，我不知道这是否是你去散步时思考的事情。但我花了很多时间。有时我会听播客，然后即使它是一个有趣的播客。如果有我正在思考或设计的一些有趣的事情，我必须关掉播客，就像，显然我的大脑想思考无论什么，那个问题有没有更好的方法。是的，当你的大脑安静时，我有一个关于那个的演讲。我不确定它是否有很好的事实依据，但这是我前段时间在我们当地聚会上做的一个经验性演讲，关于将你大脑的两面都带到工作中去解决问题的想法。演讲叫《铁匠与园丁》。哦，是的。
These are two personas that we use in writing code. Like the Blacksmith is forging code trying to get the machine to Benthol will. The Gardner is the more subconscious side. of our brain, which is also working on the problem if we're working on the meaty problem over the course of some time, right? This is why stepping away from the machine is a good debugger. This is why going for a walk. This is why you realize the answer to the problem in the shower, right?
这是我们在写代码时使用的两个角色。就像铁匠在锻造代码，试图让机器服从意志。园丁是我们大脑中更潜意识的一面，如果我们花时间解决棘手的问题，它也在处理这个问题，对吧？这就是为什么远离机器是一个很好的调试器。这就是为什么去散步。这就是为什么你在淋浴时意识到问题的答案，对吧？
It's a cliche. But this idea that how can we think about both sides of our minds working on the problem, and it's the blacksmith and the gardener? Yeah. I mean, should we call it there? I mean, there's some other things we could chat about, but we might leave them. Yeah, yeah.
这是一个陈词滥调。但这个想法是，我们如何思考我们大脑的两面都在处理这个问题，它是铁匠和园丁？是的。我的意思是，我们应该到此为止吗？我的意思是，还有一些其他事情我们可以聊聊，但我们可能会留着它们。是的，是的。
Maybe next time. Yeah, well, there's a bunch of stuff we can talk about, but one of the things that didn't end up because we ended up talking about stuff was that insights that you've come across from this kind of either recreational math or recreational algorithms or... This was Steppenoff's experience, right?
也许下次吧。是的，好吧，有很多东西我们可以谈论，但其中一件没有谈到的事情，因为我们最终谈论了其他事情，就是你从这种娱乐数学或娱乐算法中得出的见解……这是 Steppenoff 的经验，对吧？
He told an anecdote about how he was ill. He had flu or something like he was ill in bed. He was sort of, you know, in that of consciousness kind of ill, kind of ill where you want to be just asleep the whole day. And he had this fever dream, I guess, where he saw, you know, basically what we now know is the fold algorithm in his head or accumulate. And he understood how this was not just a mechanical thing happening in the computer,
他讲了一个轶事，关于他生病时的情况。他得了流感或什么的，他病倒在床上。他处于那种意识模糊的状态，那种你想整天睡觉的病。他做了这个发烧梦，我想，他看到了，你知道，基本上就是我们现在所知的折叠算法在他的脑海里，或者累加。他理解了这不仅仅是计算机中发生的机械事情，
but an implementation of this mathematical idea, right? And in that moment, he saw how computer programs could be, he saw how generic programming could work, basically. Yeah. Well, I've never had a fever dream due to an illness, but one can hope that we'll be enlightened the way Steppenov was. I'm not sure. Have you ever had any similar experiences like that?
而是这个数学思想的实现，对吧？在那一刻，他看到了计算机程序可以是什么，他看到了通用编程基本上是如何工作的。是的。好吧，我从来没有因为生病而做过发烧梦，但人们可以希望我们能像 Steppenov 那样被启迪。我不确定。你有没有过类似的经历？
Luckily, I don't get very sick very often. But most of my good ideas, you know, my output cue for picking up the answers to problems, if you're like, is not necessarily in the shower or on a walk. but it's early, early in the morning when I wake up before the alarm and I'm just dozing and my mind has been dreaming about the problem or something and then I realize how to solve it. That's where I find my inspirations. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com
幸运的是，我不太经常生病。但我大部分好的想法，你知道，我获取问题答案的输出队列，如果你愿意的话，不一定是在淋浴或散步时。而是在清晨，当我醒来，在闹钟响之前，我只是在打瞌睡，我的大脑一直在梦见这个问题或什么的，然后我意识到如何解决它。这就是我找到灵感的地方。一定要查看这些节目笔记，无论是在你的播客应用程序中还是在 ADSPthepodcast.com 上
for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. I am the anti-brace. Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。我是反括号。哈哈哈哈哈哈。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。